brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment and one of the sort of the
grub worms looking for themes in GDC or
all these different years and I guess we
haven't seen a lot of it just yet but
virtual reality has been like the sort
of the drum that's been getting louder
and louder as people been banging it for
the past couple years and this is a year
that like we're seeing the HTC cell foot
valve and there's a bunch of other
companies getting involved in it
obviously Morpheus and oculus Alexander
is somebody who's made like a
first-person game about sending people
into like bizarre like unnatural spaces
what do you think about the revolution
in virtuality are you believer do you
think there's a lot of work to be done
people people would think that I would
be a believer like yeah I walked in here
and Brad was like that I was like I was
like you look glowy you're like the
target market like told me this I'm like
no I'm like the hottest sell ever you
know it's like everyone is like oh my
god this is the future now and I'm like
these are all the issues in it you know
yes it's the future in like 10 years and
like all but can't you say and I'm like
no yes I can see all of the issues that
you're not talking about you know I one
I desperately wanted to be cool yeah but
every time I put it on I'm just like oh
my god what type of stuff stands out to
you is like as that just breaks your
immersion or makes it feel like it's not
working everything okay so many so many
things so like you get things like you
know there was there was all this talk
about presents and like you know people
you actually feel like you're there and
you'd you know you've got a demo where
there's this ledge and you're in this
room and some people they get vertigo no
and I look at that and the first thing I
do is I take a step forward and I'm like
well I'm just floating in the air like
yeah emerging John you know then you get
another one's like here we've
realistically rendered the current room
that you're in so I go to rage for a
door handle and like all I have no hands
why did you show me this thing like
every time someone tries to say this is
this is reality I'm like these are all
of the reasons but it's not so will they
fix it by like making you know things
that since your hands are like what
Bob's doing with the weather no because
there's this is this is a deep rabbit
hole of issues you know once you fix one
issue it just reveals all of the other
issues and this is this is the uncanny
valley problem that we had with graphics
for ages you know look at this
screenshot of the most realistic face
you've ever seen and in the moment you
see it animated it's like that looks
like [ __ ] yeah that's a robot you know
it just instantly breaks like Agent
Smith in the matrix and and it's like
I'm on that one you like like we've kind
of climbed out of it sort of but even at
the peak of it it's like yeah it still
just looks like a fake all you need is
one eyeball not at work right so does it
i did still at fully by for example with
like the interaction stuff you make
people be like oh we do crack your hands
and we'll be all 121 and if I get
something where it's like here's a cup
and I go to grab that cup and I do this
yeah my my character game will be
holding this cup and I'm sitting here
like this yeah and my brain is just
gonna be like wait that doesn't math 121
like ultimate offensive emotion is
instantly God yeah because there's no
feedback or there's no like tactile
haptic feedback yeah so what's the
solution to that Felicity I never create
a system that's really really it's gonna
be a destination gaming you know we're
gonna take a warehouse and everybody
puts a header on and you get a guy on
your around shoot each other that's the
only thing that virtual reality is gonna
do right right now valor destination
game is the worst thing I've ever heard
right now a bunch of people who are like
you know people are genuinely excited
about this and that's great it means
you'll get lots of content there are
lots of people that are working on
solving a bunch of these things some
people like to just excuse these things
and be like oh but yeah but it'll be
cool in five years I'm like cool no come
back in five years it's not cool to me
now because of these issues if you want
me to be excited about it now then I
need to see games that i like this is
this is virtual in reality these are all
the reasons why we know it's not going
to map to being a realistic simulation
so we've specifically built something
that breaks your brain away from that
like yeah you know Brad was talking you
know it's not even like necessarily the
best example it's just a nice example of
the game where you've got your dolphin
in the classroom oh yeah I didn't even
this yeah but yeah you're like you're a
dolphin in a classroom and you're taking
a test and you know any of the answers
cuz like you're not really dolphin
you're pretending to be an awesome and
so the whole game is like you can't get
up from your chair and you need to try
to like look over at the other dolphins
that I guess really but then you can't
like us a teacher see you like looking
at somebody else's work and triggers
it's like a like a
in the classroom simulator but like they
they catch it in this ridiculous thing
where like your your [ __ ] dolphin
that's just like it's just totally
absurd in like and like yeah let's
understand we don't handful who cares if
like your dog yeah you know you can't
like put her head through so yes it
would like the games that really like
embrace those limitations and
constraints I think are gonna be the
ones that really really stand out in
this generation I mean once you get to
the you know what is this thing called
the vibe that we call oh yeah the vote
ever you just like all these
first-generation like consumer-facing
things are probably going to be kind of
janky yeah why are you laughing that is
the very survival whatever yeah the vibe
we can all agree that real [ __ ]
stupid news I you know I thought the
Vita was kind of a bad name but yeah a
lot of people don't we you feel like
normally we do is still a terrible name
that's still bad that hasn't come around
xbox uh well the virtual reality game I
played at the mix last night actually
was a two player game and I think we've
talked about it before on the show but
what one person had the headset on and
the other person had a binder it's like
he talking nobody explodes right no one
that's a good thing because embracing
the isolation that you've got with this
headset yeah and that's like and you
wouldn't want to get up and walk around
and explore in this world I think that's
the thing that is very difficult for all
these is that it's like virtual reality
we're gonna put you into this world you
explore it it's like wow the hell am I
gonna do that like by mouth looking and
West being around a while I do this like
it's just I just don't know um yeah I I
feel like I'm kind of in a Sarah this
whole virtual reality thing too but yeah
it's this guy I just pick up on it maybe
Bob you know she's got some good points
man yeah I don't know it feels like when
you when you frame it like that it does
feel like some of the times we're almost
like willingness we're like we wanted to
work so bad that we're just like yeah
it's all right like I know 80 and
isolation was kind of like I was like
poke around corners are forgetting where
the keyboard was and all that [ __ ] but
it's like yeah it's fine if we all just
like hold our hands together and then
chant along it'll be okay one of the one
of the things that like like I don't it
will probably catch on and it's probably
gonna be the biggest thing and I'll look
like a beginning that's the one okay you
know would be the first time uh but the
the people that are like showing it off
I feel like it's really
hard for it to catch on because you're
like like here at center put on this
headset and I'm so excited to show you
this thing and share with you in he puts
the headset on and then he's just like
just do it you know the oculus face
think he's doing that and then me and
then let's say you come into and we're
all like looking at it and we're all
like what do you see now exactly see
what about what you and describe it well
and we're all just looking at you like
some kind of two days let you see what
they see yeah that's true sometimes they
will like put that um if you're dealing
here oh yeah weird bug is that the other
two like orbs with a big lake be a
rapper I don't know it's just like that
you're like what the hell is that it's
basically like like watching some you
just play video on TV you can walk in
the room right happening it's like it's
kind of shared experience and stuff but
like coming in the room and having
somebody with like the virtual reality
headset on you're just like I don't know
what they're doing what are they doing
what what is happening I just I feel so
disconnected from the person that's like
in the virtual reality thing that I'm
just like until it gets the point where
it's like so cheap that I can be like
what's happening let me put my on and
now we're in there together we're
exploring the virtual world together you
know we're like it's like yeah everybody
in the room has one and it's like we can
all kind of do it together but then it's
like why don't we all just like hang out
all this like drink a beer that's there
you go that's like that's like put your
[ __ ] phone down whatever put your
phone down we're like having dinner you
know it's like the future of virtual
reality is just having orgies and going
up going to the pub Greg virtual reality
will be a big thing yeah no dad this
isn't the Saints [ __ ] technology at work
on it absolutely we'll go somewhere all
I'm saying is that I have a bunch of
issues with it right yeah and in five or
ten years I will think it's an amazing
thing give it all of that development
what I wanted so few people are coming
out and being like ok look this isn't
the super immersive thing that you want
but it's cool in these small ways like
just pay attention to these small assets
these small parts of it that we're
getting right suspend your disbelief
you're not gonna have any feet it's okay
just look up and imagine you're looking
at a strange night sky with two moons in
it before but like also i mean it's
understandable why they're not doing
that because that's the worst way the
cells it's terrible gosh what is your
co-workers way to be like here to be
will
I guess it's fine put this on your face
no you gotta be like oh my god you're
gonna explore over to a world right an
example of something that I was like
yeah I can see how that's like solving a
problem yeah would be like a virtual OS
you know so rather than to have it
having one my one screen or having to
buy like [ __ ] 10 screens been
thousands of dollars I can put on my
headset while I'm programming i can have
programming stuff here i can have my
game over there i can have like other
[ __ ] over here so then it's like it's a
good working environment that would be
way too expensive for me to actually
have yeah in the real world like it's
solving a problem I don't care that I
don't have like hands and stuff because
i'm just using it as a really good
headset no that's like when I when I
tested the valve stuff like a year ago I
was like there I there's no doubt in my
mind that this is the best headset
technology I've ever used oh really all
it did was highlight the other issues
right that I still need to get over
there you go find out in five years time
I can't wait it's gonna finally be cool
unaffordable
you